hey there friends so I have learned a
lot of bad habits in my PO spinning over
the years that'll happen when you teach
yourself and goodness only knows I'm not
the only one but in particular I think
that a lot of the bad habits I picked up
revolved around POI flowers a lot of
times they're more complicated than we
think they are and creating good form
with them takes a lot of intensive and
long-term work so I want to save you
some of the work that I had to do and
share with you some of my best tips in
this
video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to give you my five
best tips for improving your POI flowers
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroar light toys spin s and
Ultra for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca beonin thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission could have asked for better
weather I've been cooped up inside all
day because it has been raining hard I
guess those April Showers decided to hit
DC right on the first but we're here to
talk flowers so let's focus on those poy
flowers are complex curves made up of
two objects that are spinning around in
space one around the other these curves
can be very Broad and wide with lobes
that face inward towards the performer
or sharper and more narrow with the loes
facing outwards away from the performer
and of course there's the whole issue of
timing and direction are the poy and
hands moving in the same direction
opposite directions and how are they
face related to each other so there's a
lot of ground that we could explore here
but in particular I want to single out
five mistakes that I made as I was
learning POI flowers that I see popping
up in a lot of other people's work too
so let's go ahead and dive in tip number
one explore volume all right so if
you're like me then not only are you
self-taught with your POI but also you
don't have anything in your background
that really made it so that your arms
were used to extending as far as they
can go in every direction and unless I'm
mistaken this also means that you
perform your flowers with little T-Rex
arms and well you're not really getting
the impact out of them that you could I
know that's a little bit of a flex and
especially if you're practicing indoors
cuz don't always have the room to do it
this way but if you can really practice
extending your arms out as far as you
can in every direction as you're
performing your flowers not this
half-hearted business but this big
business eat up that space around you
the results are going to speak for
themselves you're going to go from
flowers that are barely there to flowers
that everybody can read even from across
the
room he and more than likely bigger arms
is also going to mean that you're going
to have to adjust something else about
the way that you perform your flowers
namely where do those pesky pedals go
tip number two pedal placement so this
one is a really common problem if you
started off with py Trix like weaves or
butterflies because they basically
require your hands not to move around
much but at the same time you do have to
maintain a steady tempo with how fast
the POI beats and this becomes a problem
when you switch to doing flowers cuz
you're used to keeping your Poise
spinning at that same rate regardless of
whether it's appropriate to the flower
or not so the solution here is to
realize that PO flowers are a completely
different beast and start off by
learning your extensions namely try
moving your arms and po around in big
giant circles and then work to control
the number of times that you actually
spin the Poise you're moving around you
can start off just by doing a single
pedal and then work your way up to doing
two petals at opposite ends of that big
extension Circle and then work your way
up to doing four pedals or if you really
want to get exotic here you can try
doing three pedals it's totally up to
you incidentally the same thing is
almost certainly true about your
anti-spin flowers as well depending upon
how you learn them you may find yourself
inching your hands along in an attempt
to try and keep the beat of the POI
consistent or you might be doing that
thing where you're moving between pedals
in such a way that two petals are kind
of swallowed up into each other like so
for anti-spin flowers I really do think
that the best way to go about it is to
learn them via linear isolations when
you're thinking of it more as being a
stall down or a stall up as you're going
across the center of the pattern that
makes it way easier to spot where those
pedals are going to be when you finally
expand your hand out to a full path for
a flower if you're curious about the
technique for learning how to do this I
have several videos that are done on the
topic I will go ahead and link to one of
them down in the description as well as
up in the car if you're watching on
YouTube learning to clearly Define where
you want those pedals to go is going to
make a huge difference in terms of how
these patterns
read if you're used to seeing just a
gobbledygook of different Loops when you
try to create footage or photographs
around these goodness this is going to
fix you right
[Music]
up and of course now that you've got
your pedals placed properly the next
step is we're going to make sure that
your arms are actually getting all the
lift they need in order to make those
pedals pop tip number three getting
vertical so I'll confess that I was
really amazed when I first started to
learn flowers just how much shoulder
work there was in it like it's not
simply that thing that you can just move
your hands around in teeny circles in
front of you you really have to make
sure that your hands are getting above
your head as you're performing each of
those flowers and well I definitely
needed some conditioning in order to get
there see even when I was actually
reaching far to either side with my
flowers and getting my petal placement
right I was still doing this thing where
the hand that was going across the top
of the flower would get to maybe I level
at best I really wasn't used to having
to reach high and above my head in order
to really make these patterns pop that
took a little bit of work so I will just
say that one of the steps here is that
you definitely have to learn how to get
your shoulders used to doing that kind
of high-intensity work one of my
favorite exercises to do this is to
actually practice just doing shoulder
lifts over and over again with my arm
straight out to the sides switching to
bending my elbows back and forth and
then just opening and closing my hands
with them pointing straight up towards
the sky I'll do eight sets of eight for
each in order to just get my shoulders
used to being engaged for that long it's
going to burn at first but you'll thank
me for this in the long run and the
difference this makes is huge again look
at the top part of these pedals when I'm
just going past my
eyeballs and then look for when I'm
actually stretching here what a
[Music]
difference all right so for this next
one I'm going to have to get hyp
specific because there is one timing IND
Direction mode with flowers that always
still sometimes drives me crazy we're
going to dive into what happens in the
split time opposites tip number four
crossing the streams so this is actually
just a problem that pops up with human
anatomy in general as it turns out
whenever we're going across our Center
if we keep our hands even with our
shoulders there's a little bit of
horizontal width between them and of
course the default that happens as a
result of that is we wind up in a place
where the top and bottom part of our
split time opposites flowers are
displaced just a little bit horizontally
one of those things that I try and get
my students to do very very frequently
is just hang out in Split time opposites
with one hand up and one hand down in
order to get down their flowers and the
problem is when you have your hands
displaced to either side it doesn't look
as cleanly as when you get them
perfectly along the same line Nick woy
actually teaches a fantastic exercise
for this namely you find yourself a door
jam and you practice going from having
your hands together at the side to
making contact at the door jam right on
your body Center more than likely you're
going to find that one hand gets there
before the other and going to have to do
some adjusting in order to figure out
how to make them arrive at exactly the
same time but the results are easy
enough to be read by everybody once you
get your hands to cross your Center Line
at exactly the same
time it cleans up the pattern like you
wouldn't believe for both you and your
[Music]
audience all right so we've talked about
the placement of pedals we've talked
about a ridiculously specific Quirk of
timing and Direction and we have talked
about making sure that we're getting big
and wide with our arms so what's left
well we have to learn how to do it both
forwards as well as backwards trick
number five learn it both ways yeah I
know we're all so enthusiastic about
learning our flowers that very
frequently we forget that there is both
a forwards as well as a backwards to
each of them and well we never get true
freedom of movement without it and
freedom of movement is one of the
reasons that you learn flowers to begin
with and let's face it as much of a drag
as it is when we get to the point where
we can do our flowers in both directions
it also gets us to a place where we can
spin with them where we can switch
Direction on them when we want to it
also just makes the timing and Direction
Change is much much easier when we get
around to doing them really it's just a
good idea overall and again I know this
is a bummer but as you're learning every
timing in Direction mode with your POI
it does help to learn how to do the
opposite direction at the same time too
goodness it can be confusing but hey why
not do all of the work at the same time
rather than splitting it up into two
parts that might take you longer and in
the long run might mean that you favor
one side over the other either way this
is just a good practice to adopt if
we're already in a place where we're
trying to learn all of the things why
not learn all of all of the things it's
just going to make you a better po
spinner in the
[Music]
end so clearly we are just scratching
the surface here there is so much more
out there to learn about po flowers and
if you want to go further down the
rabbit hole you're in luck because that
is the topic of the flow Circle for this
month the flow circle is an exclusive
lesson that is available only to my
patreon subscri scribers this month
we're covering flowers specifically
everything from arm exercises to get
down every time in Direction mode in the
easiest way for your shoulders as well
as an entire intensive on how to get
down split times same direction flowers
if you're interested in checking that
out head on over to patreon.com
drexfactor poy and sign up the first
lesson is available now what was your
biggest struggle in learning POI flowers
is it something that I mentioned on this
list leave me a comment and let me know
also be sure to like share and subscribe
to help other people find this video and
to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible if
it were not for my amazing supporters on
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now if you like
the videos that I produce there's an
easy way to make sure that I get an
opportunity to produce more of them head
on over to patreon at
patreon.com Factor poy and sign up you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if you
enjoyed these tips on how to do POI
flowers you might also enjoy the video
that I uploaded teaching how to do POI
flowers in only 30 minutes I will go
ahead and link to that down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and Flo today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace